[موسيقى]
30 الف سجين ايراني قتلوا بدم بارد في
مجزره عام
1988 احداث لا تمحو ذكراها المؤلمه السنون
العداله ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن المجزره هما
مطلب وحلم اسر ضحايا المجزره فبعض
العائلات لا تعلم لماذا اعدم احبابهم واين
جثتهم حتى اليوم
[موسيقى]
في المره الاولى التي اعتقلوا فيها شقيقي
لم يكن لديهم اي شيء ضده لذلك اطلقوا
الصراحه في المره الثانيه اعتقلوه ونقلوه
الى سجن سري خاص للتعذيب
وعندما
[موسيقى]
ذهبت امي واختي لرؤيته اصبح شعره الاسود
ابيض بالكامل وفقد كل اسنانه بسبب التعذيب
[موسيقى]
شقيقي في صيف عام
1988 ومعه الاف السجناء السياسيين ولم
تتحقق العداله لهذه الاعدامات ولم نعلم
حتى الان لماذا تم اعدامهم واقصد هنا من
خلال القنوات الرسميه ولم نجد جثته واين
دفن ما زالت هناك كثير من الاسئله حول هذه
المجزره
صوره شقيقي لم تذكرني فقط به بل بكثير من
الاصدقاء والزملاء الذين خسرتهم انها كسره
للقلب لكن بالرغم من ذلك انا على امل ان
هذه الديكتاتوريه لن تستمر وانه لن يستطيع
كسر كل الايرانيين وفي النهايه سيكون
النصر لنا الناس في ايران تستحق الحريه
خلف قضبان سجن افين سيء السمعه اسرار
مخيفه تحدث عنها سجناء سابقون ومنظمات
حقوقيه تعذيب الممنهج وبترو للاطراف
واعتداء على سجينات هذه القصص سنكشفها في
هذه المهمه الخاصه مع الناجين من السجن
والذين فروا الى كندا
[موسيقى]
عندما كنا في الزنزانه كنا نحو 116 سجلا
في غرفه حجمها سته امتار في سته وهناك
حمامان او ثلاثه للاستحمام واستخدام
المرافق الصحيه والوضوء ويجب على كل شخص
ان يستخدمها لمده لا تتعدى العشر دقائق
والا
وعندما جاء احد الحراس وسال من يهتم ويدير
هذه الغرفه قلت له انا فجلدني خمسه وسبعين
جلده بسبب تاخر بعض السجناء في استخدام
الحمامات
[موسيقى]
كنت احد الناجين من سجن افين حيث تم
الافراج عنك قبل باسابيع قليله قبل حدوث
مجزره عام 1988 هل تعتبر نفسك من
المحظوظين لانه افرج عنك قبل هذه المجزره
وتكون واحد من الضحايا ابدا لن اقول انا
محظوظ بانني لم اكن جيدا مثل بقيه
المعدومين اعتقد انني لم اكن صالحا مثلهم
[موسيقى]
الشخص الذي كان معي كان صادقا جدا لكن انا
لم اكن مثلهم
عندما اعتقلوا بقينا لمده اربعه او خمسه
اشهر والدتي لم تعلم اين هو وبعد سته اشهر
سمحوا لها بمعرفه انه معتقل لديهم لكنهم
قالوا انهم لا يعلمون لماذا اعتقل والى
متى سيبقى في السجن والدتي توفيت في عمر
التاسعه والاربعين عاما بجلطه قلبيه لانها
لم تتحمل الوضع
في عام
1988 اصدر الخميني فتوى باعدام الاف
السجناء السياسيين
اعدامات نفذت خارج نطاق القضاء لجان الموت
تشكلت وانطلقت الى سجون عده في طهران لكن
النصيب الاكبر في الاعدامات كان لنزلاء
سجني جوهرداشت وايفين
[موسيقى]
قبل انتهاء الحرب مع العراق او ما تسمى
بشرب قلاع السم اي قبل ايقاف اطلاق النار
اصدر الخميني فتوى وقبل شهور عده من مجزره
صيف
1988 تم فصل السجناء واخرون نقلوهم من سجن
الى اخر حيث كانوا يتهياون للاعدامات وهذا
ما اطلق عليه لجان الموت وكان من ضمن
اللجان ابراهيم رئيسي والاشخاص الذين
شاركوا اصبحت لهم مناصب في النظام حتى ان
رئيسي اصبح انذاك وزيرا للعداله ثم نصبه
خامنئي رئيسا للبلاد
ذريعه يبحث عنها النظام الايراني لاعدام
السجناء السياسيين الذين يعارضون سياسته
ويطالبون بالحريه فبعد انتهاء الحرب
العراقيه الايرانيه عام
1988 توغل مجاهدوا خلق في عمليه اطلق
عليها النور الابدي في محاوله للاطاحه
بالنظام الذي ضعفت قدراته بسبب الحرب مع
جارته لثماني سنوات حيث يقول محللون ان
هذه العمليه اعطت زريعه للنظام لاعدام
الالاف دوده محاكمه او ادله او حتى شهود
فالخوف والضعف كان يسيطران على نظام خميني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لنعود في التاريخ الى عام 1988 كيف تلقيت
خبر المجزره التي راح ضحيتها 30 الف سجين
سياسي
كنت حزينه جدا وبكيت كثيرا ليس فقط من
اجله بل من اجل كل الشباب الذين اعدموا
عندما سمعت الاخبار بكيت كثيرا ليس فقط
على ابن عمي بل على جميع الشباب الذين
كانوا يدعمون مجاهدي خلق لانهم جميعهم
كانوا ابرياء
[موسيقى]
عندما استلم خميني الحكم عذب وسجن وقتل
الناس وكانت حربهم مع العراق ذريعه لقتل
اي شخص يعارضه واصر على الاستمرار في
الحرب المدمره مع العراق رغم انه كانت
هناك فرص كثيره لتحقيق السلام مع الجار
العراق لكنه دمر كل المصادر الايرانيه حتى
ان كثيرا من الناس خرجوا في احتجاجات وحتى
الحرس الثوري الايراني قال للنظام انهم
ليست لديهم مصادر كافيه للاستمرار في هذه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
جرافات نقلت جثث المعدومين عشوائيا حفر
كبيره كانت معده مسبقا وجاهزه حفرت في
مقابر عده دفن فيها السجناء السياسيون
جماعيا وحتى اللحظه تبحث هذه العائلات عن
جثث احبابهم التي لم يسلمها النظام لهم
[موسيقى]
لم يعيدوا لنا جثته طالبنا بجثته كثيرا
لكنه تم دفنه في مقبره في خفران لكن باي
قبر في المقبره لا نعلم
[موسيقى]
لم يسلمون جثته ولم يخبرونا اين هي بعدها
ذهبوا الى مقبره بهجت زهره ثم سالوا احد
العاملين في المقبره ووصفوا له شكله فقال
لهم اظن ان هذا قبره ووضعوا له صوره وبعد
اسابيع عندما زاروا القبر مره اخرى وجدوا
عائله اخرى تجلس الى جانب القبر لانها
الصوره الوحيده عند القبر
[موسيقى]
ليس من السهل الحديث مع اشخاص قضى سنوات
طويله من عمرهم في المعتقل سنوات يصفونها
بالمظلمه حيث كانوا يقضون ليال من التوتر
والخوف بانتظار لحظه الاعدام
[موسيقى]
جرائم ضد الانسانيه هكذا صنفها المجتمع
الدولي ومنظمات حقوقيه ادله جمعتها منظمه
هيومن رايت سوتش تثبت ان الافعال الشنيعه
التي ارتكبت بحق السجناء ترقى الى مستوى
جرائم ضد الانسانيه بموجب القانون الدولي
وتجب محاسبه المسؤولين عنها وبالفعل حدثت
اول محاكمه في السويد لحميد نوري احد
المتهمين في الاعدامات الجماعيه
[موسيقى]
ماذا قال لوالدته في زيارتها الاخيره اليه
في السجن وماذا حدث ايضا في المقبره عندما
ذهبت لرؤيه جثته
الزياره الاخيره في سجن ايفل سالته والدته
لماذا لم تقل لهم انك كنت على خطا او اي
شيء مثل هذا البعض وتخرج من السجن قال
لوالدته انا اخترت هذا الطريق وساستمر حتى
نهايه الزياره كان يعرف انه سيعدم عندما
وصل خلف الجدار ثم نظر الى والدته ثلاث
مرات بطريقه كانت اشبه بالوداع وبعد
اسابيع تم اعدامه اتصل شخص من السجن يدعى
داود لاشكري وقال ان صنلا بسبب بقائه
واصراره على معتقده اعدمناه
[موسيقى]
اغلب الوقت كانوا تحت التعذيب الجسدي
والنفسي تخيلي كانت والدتي تحمل معها كل
هذه الالام وهي تنتظر ابنها يعود الى
المنزل يوما ما وبعد سبع سنوات في السجن
والامل تم اعدامه ومن معه حابين
عندما تقلت كنا تسعه اشخاص وبعدها اعدم
سته منا
اعدموهم دون اي سبب لان النظام دكتاتوري
في ايران اعدمهم لمطالبتهم بالحريه كنا
فقط ندافع من اجل الحريه وهم يعلمون ذلك
ولاننا ندعم مجاهدي خلق لانهم ضد نظام
الملالي
[موسيقى]
المعتقلون في سجن اذينهم من السياسيين
ومزدوجي الجنسيه يطلق على السجن ايضا اسم
جامعه افين نظرا لكثره عدد المثقفين
المعتقلين فيه والذين ترتفع اصواتهم ضد
النظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
ان شقيقها المعدوم كان عبقريا بعلمه وكان
مسالما ولم يحمل سلاحا في حياته كان دائما
يدافع عن حقوق الانسان والمراه ويعلمهم ان
ايران بلد غني لكن الشعب لم يستفد من
ثرواته بسبب الملالي واستغلالهم للسلطه
كان يدافع من اجل حريه ايران اتذكر عندما
كنت في السادسه عشر وكان يكبرني بسبع
سنوات كان يقول دائما ان لدينا بلدا غنيا
ولدينا الكثير من المصادر والقوه وكان
ايضا ضد الشاه
مجزره تركت اثرا كبيرا في نفوس الايرانيين
حتى من غير الداعمين لمجاهدي خلق الشهود
الذين عاشوا تلك الايام القاسيه اقروا بان
ابراهيم رئيسي الرئيس الحالي لايران كان
عنصرا فعالا في لجان الموت
[موسيقى]
عندما ظهرت رساله ايه الله منتظر المسجله
التي ذكر فيها ان ابراهيم رئيسي كان يطلب
السماح له باعدام عدد اكبر ومنتظر قال انه
لا يوافقهم الراي لانها جريمه انسانيه
وسنحاسب عليها ايضا في الرساله ذكر ان
خميني وابنه احمد يعتقدان ان مجاهدي خلق
يجب ان تتم ابادتهم والقضاء عليهم حتى اخر
شخص سواء كان ذا مرتبه عاليه او لا هذه
كانت الفلسفه التي اعتمد عليها في مجزره
عام
في العاصفه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترجليه الايرانيه في كندا ان ثوره
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها مدن عده داخل
ايران ما هي الا تراكمات ونتيجه حتميه
لسنوات عاشها الشعب في الظلم والاضطهاد
والاعدامات والقمع
[تصفيق]
اعتقد وبصدق ان ما يحدث الان هو نتيجه لا
عداله والاعدامات والتعذيب التي ينفذها
النظام اعتقد ان هذه من ضمن الاسباب وان
المجتمع الان انفجر وقال كفى يعني كفى
واعتقد ان هذه الاحتجاجات وانفجار
التظاهرات نامل انها ستغير النظام
[موسيقى]
هذا ما حدث لكل مجاهد خلق في مجزره عام
1988 وفي ذلك الوقت كان يوجد ابراهيم
رئيسي واعتقد ان خامن اختار رئيس مره اخرى
لانه يعتقد اننا في
1988 لكن لا نحن ليس كما كنا لقد حان
الوقت وانه القرار الاخير لتغيير النظام
لا رئيس ولا غيره يمكن ان يغير اي شيء
الشهود والناجون من المجزره يعتقدون انهم
سيحصلون على اجابات لاسئلتهم بعد ان ينتهي
هذا النظام ويحصل على الوثائق التي يخفيها
[موسيقى]